hey hey hey free code camp people Chris
coiour here I'm one of the founders of
code pen I know that free code camp as
you work your way through it there's you
know an exercise or to where they
optionally you can pop over to code pen
to do the work to complete the thing
which is just so cool but anyway I'm
just gonna talk about code pen and how
it works and introduce you to it in case
you just have no idea or are interested
in it and how it might be able to help
you on your learning to code journey
because it certainly can do that so I'm
just here logged out on code button code
bin as a site that yeah just like free
code camp you can have an account on and
it's free to sign up so if you're
interested in signing up just hit sign
up and it'll take you right to the free
sign up and you can sign up through your
github account or just with your email
address or whatever when you land here
on code pen you know it kind of tells
you what code pen is but there's all
these all these things here all these
cards down here and these will always be
different every time you come to code
pen because there we picked them out the
staff of code pen picks out cool things
that people are doing could be you you
know if you sign up for code pen and do
something cool on here we'll pick it and
just just to show off interesting things
and there's just dozens and dozens of
these get picked every day you know so
come around and check out what people
are doing in code pen is like so what
are these things and what what are they
exactly that these people have made we
call them pens on code pen it's one of
the things that you can create on code
pen probably the most popular thing and
I'm gonna go ahead and do it actually
you know what let me let me login to my
own account here I'll log in through
github and I'll pop into my own account
which is just it's gonna show me the
same stuff here but I'm gonna go to this
create menu and I'm gonna see it create
new pen and this is kind of the heart
and soul of code pen is the editor so
you're learning to code on free code
camp you can do some of that coding
right here on code menu just type HTML
type CSS type JavaScript and the results
of what you're doing show up here in
this kind of big white area the preview
area over here so if I were to type
hello campers as I type you can see that
being output over here or I could for
example make an h1 tag you know a big
header tag
I can say hello and that's gonna render
over here as well I can write CSS as
well let me target that h1 tag and write
color equals red this is valid CSS and
it's you know my hello has become red
over here how cool is that JavaScript
works in the same way I could say you
know var you know a equals one or work
on my JavaScript skills and I could say
console.log a and it's gonna output one
of course I can even open a console here
and I'll show me those results we have a
console writing code pen so I've made my
first pen congratulations myself I've
done good work here so what else can you
do here let's like do something a little
bit more robust let's make like a card
component so you see I've just typed
card and then press tab right there
that's Emmet which you might be familiar
with that works in lots of different
editors helps me write HTML a little
quicker and it has some CSS stuff as
well let's have an h2 and I'll say my
card let's say it'll have some P tag in
there I'm gonna type lorem and hit tab
and you'll get a bunch of gibberish text
that lorem ipsum text it's called just
filler text you know let's say body and
HTML are have a height of a hundred
viewport height units and then it's
display see it's helping me out with
code completion here that's kind of nice
let's say it's display grid of that
modern fancy thing and that we're going
to place items which is how grid works
in the center and that's gonna put my
card in the middle and if I say my card
say has a max width maybe of 4 or 500
pixels let's say it'll go in the middle
maybe even narrow you'll see that it's
kind of centering in the middle that's
nice that's nice I don't need my
JavaScript I could say whisk that away I
can kind of control the look of how
things are going here on code pen I can
move my editors over here if it's more
convenient or put them at the top I can
do all kinds of stuff so again I'm just
saving my pen as I go I can title it and
say playing with cards for example and
I'll be able to find this again pretty
easily at anytime I can jump back to my
dashboard that's available in my user
menu here or any better that looks like
this it'll say your dashboard I can find
that again that's it's forever it's
never going away I go under pens and I
could say show me you know my recently
made it cards here's my playing with
card ones it's right here so I could pop
that open again or if I you know have
lost track of it I could search for card
or something or what did I call it
playing with cards I can get it to show
up but it's listing them by popularity
here so I could say show me my newest
ones first that's gonna find me in my
card anyway the point is your work is
saved here so it's kind of a it's kind
of nice you don't have to worry about
losing the files or anything like that
so let's see you might notice that the
the CSS up here says s CSS after that
that's a CSS preprocessor or something
that's really easy to use on code pen so
if I click that little cog next to it
there or open my settings and go to the
CSS tab well for one thing it's gonna
show me the title and I might have a
description here that says like oh just
showing free code camp people some
things just adjusting just you know
whatever I have a description there I
can use markdown there and tag things
but we were talking about pre-processors
instead of saying none just regular CSS
I had particularly picked out s CSS
which is you know a sass preprocessor
meaning I could do something like I
don't know dollar sign BG color equals
what's like a cool color fog dog that's
one of my favorites fo6 do6 yeah and
that's not valid CSS that doesn't mean
anything in the language CSS but it does
you know if I say HTML background now I
can use that variable that I just
created background color and it's gonna
make that oh but now my card is weird
I'm gonna have to say background white
and padding maybe of two rim or
something that's a nice-looking card
component isn't it cool so I'm using a
CSS preprocessor there and there's lots
of different versions of HTML
preprocessor CSS preprocessors
JavaScript
preprocessors all that stuff is
available now let's see what if what if
we're learning bootstrap or we wanted
some kind of freebies out of our our our
CSS of it I could open up settings again
and notice there's more things going on
here for what I could click something
like normalize you'll see the fonts
change a little bit when I turn that on
that's kind of a CSS reset library and
it's just applying those Styles to the
pen we do want to make things like that
really quick for you
vendor prefix thing you can do for you
but let's say I want to use a library
like foundation or something I can just
click that or I could have searched for
foundation or used our quick Add to find
stuff like that now some of this stuff
changes over time so just they'll always
be searched so that's probably your your
best bet for looking for things but
anyway now that we've had added
foundation we should see some changes to
our card as well wow that's kind of cool
foundation being applied to the card as
well so lots of stuff to play around
with write your own code or bring in
libraries from elsewhere you can play
with bootstrap or Balma or whatever
these materialise fancy frameworks are
those are easy and quick to play with on
code pen so let's say I want to make a
variation of this or I found this and it
wasn't mine it was somebody else's
I'd be looking at their pen and I could
hit this fork button which will chilled
fork it from their account to my account
it'll just give me a copy of it that I
can begin playing with immediately so
I'll do that notice the URL changes so
that other one will just stay exactly
how it is forever but this new copy of
it will be totally changed you know
let's say I make the background purple
and I change it on this copy this copy
is totally unique and the other one
won't be affected in any way so that's a
way you can make kind of a variation of
a thing that's kind of neat so let's say
there's some things that I know that I
personally really like myself to work
with like I really like sass so I don't
want to turn on sass every time you
might even notice when I turned on this
pen sass was already turned on for me
that's a setting so I'll go under my
user menu here and I can pop open
settings and it's gonna take me right to
my editor settings and there's a lot of
stuff here so you know forgive it being
a little overwhelming but I can say you
know when I start a new pen my defaults
make my
default sass and turn these settings on
and I like tabs instead of spaces and
maybe I like you know gin tronic as a
font or fire code or fury code rather
than operator mono or whatever you know
you can kind of pick out your settings
maybe I'll change to a different theme
and if I come back here and reload
things will just look a little different
I'll have a little bit of different
settings there you can just make sure
code pen is comfortable for you I think
that's pretty fun okay so let's see
let's see let's see there's a couple of
other interesting things we could do
here so let's say we really like this
CSS for centering things that was really
useful for us but we want to make a
different pen that just leverages the
CSS written here but otherwise start
fresh that's kind of an interesting
thing you can do so I can take this URL
of this pen and I can tart this new pen
hasn't is nothing it's totally blank new
thing under my settings under CSS I can
put a link to that pen and close it and
I think you'll see the background go
purple because it's gonna load in the
CSS from this pen into this pen so cool
like there's no code here but the
background is already purple because
there really is some code it's the CSS
from that other pen and this one so if
we wrote card again in Road hello we're
gonna have a card in the middle here but
we didn't have to style it this time the
CSS was coming from elsewhere just like
it would have been if we loaded up
bootstrap or something like that
so that's kind of me the other way
around is let's say I wanted to use this
pen the HTML and not the CSS so I wanted
to like well let me close out that but I
want this HTML certainly I could just
copy and paste it over there or make a
fork or whatever but I can also this is
just kind of interesting thing you
should know is grab this URL and put it
in triple brackets over here paste and
it's gonna pull in the HTML from that
pen into this pen so if I make changes
to this HTML boom I'll see it over here
as well so just kind of a little
interesting trick that you may not have
known about in the past so let's do
something kind of JavaScript e41 we
might as well keep this here actually
let's just play with our original
whatever we're just playing around right
we already had a little JavaScript over
there I think we like console dot log
something we could do something a little
JavaScript D if we if we feel like it so
for example we could say like well say
when you let's put a button in here so
it feels like a real action you know
button is go away so that will be there
and it doesn't do anything because
buttons don't do anything when they're
not enough form just sitting there like
that but we could say ma I'm gonna let
go because we can write in modern
JavaScript why not write let button
equal query selector button now I have
our reference to that button and I can
use the regular Brown that browser
console if I want also I could say well
if I type button here it's not going to
be quite right because the context is
wrong right I have to avoid have to make
sure to to select the correct context
which is one of these things or you know
what if you just inspect something it
changes the context for you so if now if
I type button button button is not
defined query slow oh document document
doctor where are you free code camp
people aren't you gotta watch me so now
I'm in the right context and now if I
type button it's gonna show me come on
in my console does is button the right
thing one let button query selector for
the button elements I still think it
should be with oh it's I see that's the
one is just coming from this or whatever
but we can say the button dot add event
listener click so if you click that
button it's gonna run some code and we
can can't we stay can we stay fancy yes
sixty who look fury code has this nice
ligature button kind of thingy here
click oh it's it's click but it's we
need a click we need the event I guess
or you could just have empty if you're
not going to use the event which we're
not going to will say console dot log
clicked so I am gonna open my my console
here and you know ok
it is logging the right button at the
top of this I can always write console
dot clear which every time the pen runs
then it will clear the console instead
of it just persisting you might want it
either way but whatever so ok I click
this button over and over click click
click click that should work let button
is it not liking one for something query
selector for a button there really is a
button that's right here I'm clicking
the button add event listen I spelled it
wrong there it is
I'm so glad okay so click click click
click like we've just done a little
JavaScript or whatever that all works
perfectly well in code pen as well
should we have it actually do something
maybe we should select the card as well
it definitely wasn't that let's say the
card is the the card I know a lot of
times use query selector all but there's
only one card here we know there's only
one card so we'll just say card has you
know when you click it we're gonna say
car dot class list add away because
we've told it to go away right so we're
using a CSS so we can nest in our CS
that's a little bit that's always fun
we'll say dot or and dot away so card
dot away when the card has also has the
class away will say translate or
transform translate why the vertical
Direction like I don't know two thousand
pixels or something and if there's a
transition on the card transition trans
I should use autocomplete more my typing
skills let's like it make it take a long
time like one second when you
click this whoop it goes away but now
it's gone away how do I start over here
all that to say you can press command
shift 5 and that will rerun so it'll
refresh that's kind of a thing even if
you change this to like red or something
it's you know it's a lot of times you
change JavaScript you change HTML we
refresh the demo for you so that
sometimes works but not when you write
oops
CSS CSS we try to inject it for you
which is kind of cool because you see it
even transition from red to white there
because if you're in a particular state
like you're trying to style a drop-down
menu or something just changing the CSS
it's kind of nice to have it not refresh
the page every time if you really want
explicit refreshing I said it's command
shift 5 but you can always go under your
JavaScript settings and we I know we
haven't looked at this but surprise
surprise you can add external javascript
libraries like jQuery or react or view
or all that type of stuff and
pre-process with things like babble or
CoffeeScript and all that but what I was
gonna show you is under the behavior tab
you can say auto updating preview nope
don't want that so you'll get a run
button so you got to remember you did
this because you might make a change
like my car with exclamation points and
normally code pen would just refresh
this browser window over down here but
it's not you have to press run and then
it'll refresh and you'll see the
exclamation points down there so that's
that that's writing some JavaScript and
stuff we looked at the console we looked
at that kind of thing I have some links
we could look at here you know thing if
you're learning something more advanced
like react for example or Ajax and all
all of that kind of stuff works just
fine on code pen so here's an example
where we've loaded up the react library
and we made a Ajax call for some for
some data and pulled it in and use State
and looped over all that state and that
kind of stuff we use JSX in here too if
you if you are gonna use JSX you will
have to flip on the babble preprocessor
in in JavaScript there but that's kind
of cool
so there's something else that you
should know on code pen of course right
at the beginning of this video we
dat you know here's all this new stuff
and in fact look there's even been some
new things that have been added to the
homepage even since we this video has
even been started let's look at this pen
just for fun I have something in mind
that I was gonna show you but oh no
JavaScript this is a checkbox that oh
look how clever that is the corner of
the box becomes the check that's the
coolest thing ever saw if you wanted to
explore how that was done of course all
the code is here for you to in it's open
source code
I could fork a copy of my own and make
changes or use this even in a project of
my own so darn cool love that anyway I'm
gonna heart it because to show some love
for this pen you know even that harding
this is what i was originally going to
show you works into some algorithms on
code pen to increase its popularity and
and for one of those things we use
popularity for is search so if i look up
checkboxes in search we haven't this is
what i wanted to show you a search on
code pen and just enter that search
we're gonna show you all kinds of stuff
here oh i guess it's not showing you how
many results that are but i'll tell you
four check boxes there's probably tens
of thousands or more of results here and
we're kind of ordering them by relevance
and hearts and views and comments and
all kinds of fancy stuff here to make
sure that it when you search for stuff
you're getting really interesting
results and showing you kind of a lot of
the best stuff on code pen around that
search and even the Pens we made today
like the card and stuff that's all
findable from other people from search
so if i've named it well and added a
good description and it has a few hearts
and stuff i think that type of stuff
ends up in search and becomes part of
the kind of the code pen ecosystem which
is nice so let's see do we have a pen
open left i just want to show you a few
more things and then we'll kind of be
done so if it turns out that you really
like working in code pen or you know a
lot of people end up using it for you
know working in teams because we have
teams accounts or they they use it in a
teaching environment or they use it even
in their agency for showing clients work
that they're working on let's say it's
that one i might want to make this
private because i want to show this to
my i don't want the
world to see this yet I don't want an in
search I don't want people finding it on
my profile everybody has a profile on
code pen as well I want this to be
hidden from the world well all I have to
do is open up settings and kick it on to
private which is a pro feature of code
pen so there's that there's a few things
that kind of have to be paid for on code
pay and now look at how weird this URL
is nobody could ever find that it's not
in searches now it's totally gone from
code pen only you can see it and
somebody that you'd share that URL with
so you could share that URL with your
client they could see this and nobody
else could so just an example of a pro
feature another pro feature is like
let's say you're using it for teaching
purposes I could open the same pet in
collab mode and it looks a little
different you can see that yellow bar
there so you're kind of sure that you're
in collab mode notice that you have chat
as well here I could open this in
another browser or share this with a
friend and then we could be typing at
the same time and you could see their
cursor jumping around and adding code to
you can work together there's real-time
features of code pen that's another
example of kind of a pro feature on code
pen so so that's kind of that that's
kind of their annual and there's so much
more to code pen I haven't shown you
projects I haven't shown you professor
mode I haven't shown you asset hosting
even that's a big one maybe we'll end
with that one I can click assets down
here and it's gonna open up a your files
section which I can drag and drop stuff
like images and JavaScript and CSS or
any file that I want to here and give me
quick access to URLs to use those on
code man and then there's some things
that we give to you so let's say I
wanted to have a picture of let's see
playing cards I could do a search here
and it's gonna give me a bunch of design
assets for playing cards hopefully and I
can let's see I'm going to grab the full
background image there I'm gonna hit
escape to close it and rather than a
purple background here I'm gonna use my
new playing cards image back there and
hopefully that will pop right in there
background-image:url oh I have to hit
run ah you could have told me that and
it's so big that it's
barely even see it but it did show up
there I'll say background size contain
and that's gonna kind of squish it doll
rush covers almost the better one isn't
it background size cover run and I'll
shrink it up a little bit so we can see
the playing cards but we make those kind
of things available to you and there's
so much more but I'm gonna stop now I
hope you made it this far thanks so much
for listening code camp 3 code camp
people it's so awesome to see some of
you pop over to code pen and use it for
stuff like learning and playing good bye